معنا من اسطنبول العقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عقيد حاتم
مرحبا بك معنا هل هذه المنطقه التي تنوي
اسرائيل انشائها وتقوم بعمليات التجريف
على طول الحدود في غزه بعمق كيلو متر هي
فعليا ستقدم الامان لسكان غلاف غزه بتصورك
العسكري نعم
بدايه دعيني اقول بان هذه المنطقه العازله
التي ينوي الجيش الصهيوني اقامتها في هذه
المنطقه لا قيمه لها على المستوى العسكري
ابدا هذه المنطقه لا يمكن لها ان تؤمن
الحمايه للمناطق الاسرائيليه المتواجده في
منطقه غلاف غزه وبالتالي يعني لا لا اعرف
ما هي الجدوى التي يرمي الوصول اليها
الجيش الصهيوني والدليل على هذا بانه
الصواريخ لازالت تنطلق الان من مناطق غلاف
غزه من مناطق غزه الان من قطاع غزه في
المنطقه الشماليه والوسطى والجنوبيه
باتجاه المدن سواء كانت المحيطه او سواء
باتجاه تل ابيب بمعنى هذا بانه لن يستطيع
ان يقاف الصواريخ باتجاه هذه المناطق كما
لا يمكن ايقاف الطائرات المسيره كما
تفضلتم في التقرير قبل قليل وبالتالي وجود
هذه المنطقه العازله لن يزيد شيء في مساله
الامان بالنسبه لقطاعات المتواجده في
منطقه غلاف غزه ولكن هو يريد من هذه
المنطقه ابعاد حماس عن الحدود المنط الامر
الثاني هو ايقاف التهريب من هذه المنطقه
او التسلل باتجاه مناطق غلاف غزه يضاف الى
ذلك زياده المسافه ما بين المنطقتين بحيث
بما يؤمن الوقت الكافي لملاحظه اي تحرك
عسكري يمكن ان يكون في المستقبل لوقف اي
هجمات مستقبليه يمكن ان تقوم بها المقاومه
من هذه المنطقه وجميع هذه الاجراءات التي
يحاول الوصول عليها من خلال هذه المنطقه
لن تؤمن ايقاف مثل هذه العمليات العسكريه
يضاف الى ذلك بان هذه المنطقه التي يتكلم
عليها لا لا يوجد فيها عمق عسكري في
الداخل حتى يمكن الحصول عليه المناطق في
مدينه غزه تتراوح عمقها من مسافه 5 م الى
8 الى 14 م في احسن احوالها وبالتالي هذه
المناطق لن يبقى فيها عمق اذا ما تم اقامه
هذه المنطقه العازله يضاف الى ذلك بانه
الناس التي ستهجر من هذه المناطق لن تبقى
لها مناطق يمكن اللجوء اليها خلال الفتره
القادمه الامر الذي يثير الكثير من
التساؤلات في مساله اقامه هذه المنطقه
والاصرار على اقامتها ولكن اعتقد بانها هي
جزء من الضغوطات التي تمارس على قياده
حماس في مساله المفاوضات القادمه عق ح
عقيد حاتم قبل ان اذهب الى السؤال التالي
المتعلق بما نتحدث عنه وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه في الخبر العاجل الذي نشاهده
يتحدث بانه لم ندعم كل ما قامت به اسرائيل
ويضيف ايضا للجزيره بان اسرائيل لن تقبل
ان تدير حماس قطاع غزه بعد الحرب ولديها
الحق في ذلك واعود اليك عقيد حاتم بالنسبه
لهذه المنطقه العازله التي يجري الحديث
عنها اسرائيليا انشائها داخل اراضي
القطاع الى اي درجه تعكس بان يعني هناك
يعني فهم لطبيعه المعركه واهداف المعركه
وهناك استراتيجيه واضحه مثلا عند الطرف
الاسرائيلي ام تعكس
العكس نعم اذا ما جينا الخطه العسكريه نجد
بان هناك تخبط كبير جدا في مساله الاهداف
العسكريه التي وضعت لهذه العمليه العسكريه
يضاف الى ذلك بان اقامه هذه المنطقه
العازله بمعنى بان يجب ان يكون هناك تواجد
للقوات الصهيونيه على منطقه
الحدود المصريه الفلسطينيه وهذا ما ترفضه
مصر لحد هذه اللحظه الامر الذي قد يثير
اشكال حقيقي ما بين مصر وما بين اسرائيل
في التواجد العسكري في هذه المنطقه لان
المنطقه العازله يجب ان تكون على طول
الشريط الحدودي ال الذي يبدا من الساحل
باتجاه بيت لاهيه وصولا الى رفح الى مدينه
رفح وبالتالي هذه القضيه ستثير الكثير من
الاشكالات في الفتره القادمه يضاف الى هذا
بان الاهداف العسكريه التي انطلقت من اجل
هذه العمليه العسكريه لم يتم تحقيقها يعني
هو حتى عندما يتكلم عن المنطقه العازله
يقول بان هذه المنطقه العازله يجب ان تعمل
على ثلاثه امور الامر الاول هو نزع سلاح
حماس القضاء على القدرات ومنع اي تهديد
هابي من هذه المنطقه طيب انت الان استخدمت
القوه العسكريه بهذا الحجم وبهذه الكثافه
التدميريه ولم تستطيع ان تحقق الاهداف
فكيف ستحققها من خلال اقامه هذه المنطقه
العازله التي ستكون القطعات الصهيونيه
خارج هذه المنطقه تماما شكرا لك من
اسطنبول العقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا على المشاركه
معنا